[Music]
now we will come to various an ovation
this distance you will be going to talk
about test engine object what is
distance you let's talk about that
testing next generation this is the
paper form of the stingy
what is this stingy so first inform the
stingy is a unit testing framework when
I will drown our unit district framework
this specific - Gela there are two most
popular political framework one is unit
and one is distance these are the two in
the sink lingo for Java and if I talk
about GNA J in it it's used a lot by
developers the developer use this
particular framework a lot by the unit
testing purpose and when we talk about
testing G testing G it is used a lot by
testers why there is a discrimination
between these two frameworks then okay
what happens is you know developers are
keep on using unit from quite a long
time and they don't want to switch to
the new one that's only the thing which
I feel is they are using jled however if
I talk about this change e testing G is
having more annotations compared to
Jared is having more annotations means
more functionalities
it's what we write it here more
functionalities the latest version of J
unit is a unit for testing G it is
actually six point of that one is the
latest version of the same game for AJ
you notice it's the fourth version for J
unit there is a new version coming up
that is called as v and it may be
possible but that will be more advanced
or not what advanced but that will be
equivalent to testing G because I have
seen as in production that it is having
functionality similar to distinction so
now then we won't be able to say that
just in G
oh sorry Jane it is behind distinction
but is it not yes it is
in testing G if I talk about we will be
going through some annotations these
annotations helps us make our test more
usable easily maintainable okay if you
go ha get stuck at any point of time you
can go to the documentation of this
tangent will find eat everything clear
and very easily defined so this ng
documentation is very good so I would
suggest whenever we get time you can go
through with it but most of the 70% of
the test in G functionality is what we
are going to take a look because they
are very helpful when we talk about
testing G we always talk about view and
notation mission when we talk about
annotation what annotation is can anyone
tell me what inflation is let me create
a package here actually test in G
learning test in G is very interesting
thing
we are creating a class and we are
saying it as log in SPSS
we see here verify with valid
credentials
you
you
verify with invalid credentials
verify suppose if you have any other
test cases well let's let me just think
if you can tell me one test case of
login one is for valid potential one is
with invalid credentials you can expand
it as much as you want you but
he's ratify it with with local
installation but it we can say verify
with the special characters
SQL injection so there can be multiple
methods correct this have you observed
at any point of time whenever you are
working on Java yogurt in any programs
or anything like that have you observed
that is one annotation comes up there is
one line comes out that is at the rate
override sometimes at the rate or
suppress warnings anyone of you have
have you ever seen this kind of
statement
movin it change
okay we also get deprecated
let me come back from that so
whatever you write on top of your method
with at the rate sign and anything pulls
that that will be considered as an
annotation on top of a method on top of
echo pass anywhere okay these are called
as annotations and it can be anything I
will say Edgar it is I so it's not what
you will define this is you will say any
name to it no these are the annotations
which are being provided by tests in G
and everything whatever you will be
going to define here has some
functionality attached to it has some
functionality attached to it so it's not
that it is just for the name purpose it
will be going to add up some
functionalities okay there's a thing but
okay that's fine
[Music]
so whenever I am talking about
annotation I am talking about few things
which I am going to add on top of
methods or on top of the class okay
and they actually plays an important
role in your particular class or in your
methods before I tell you about
annotations that what all annotations do
we have in test ng let me tell you how
you are going to download this extension
first of all they said J and a generator
is a pre-installed J it is pre-installed
in eclipse but testing G is not if you
have to download this then just go to
help
eclipse marketplace
wait for it to go up
you
right here there ng in defined obviously
hang let it come okay clear test Eng and
search for it
so to install it you write or you go to
hell Eclipse marketplace and inside that
you mentioned Destin G when you get the
distance you will see here a test in G
for Eclipse just click on install this
is how install button will look like
click on that and insert the same G and
done testing G will be installed in your
system
ok let's talk about few annotations in
testing G we are talking about
annotations from quite a long time now
let's write some annotations at the rate
before sweet anti read before guests at
the rate before class anti-red before
method and the rate test enter it after
method enter it after
at the rate after taste enter it after
suit enter it before
Group entered it after group entered
data provider and and think if I have
entered it parameter okay these are the
annotations what we have in 15 G hi
there if you liked this video subscribe
to the simple learn YouTube channel and
click here to watch similar videos to
nerd up and get certified click here